it is a privilege tonight to have with
us a writer who at a very young age has
already turned out an astonishing body
of prose her book singular intimacy's
becoming a doctor at Bellevue published
by beacon press in Boston and the this
is of course the publishing house of our
very good friend Helen at one this is an
extraordinary account of grief of death
of compassion and recovery in the
tumultuous corridors and wards of a City
Hospital in New York if you've read the
book you know that these stories are
riveting and that the characters are
truly unforgettable but like another
doctor whose medical training came at a
New York Hospital William Carlos
Williams the poet playwright novelist
traveler activist father letter writer
tireless general practitioner and
deliverer of hundreds of babies in
Rutherford New Jersey dr. Aubrey has
many lives she is co-founder and editor
of the Bellevue literary review wife
mother of two small children who we've
all met this week bicyclist serious
traveler and sometimes student of dance
at the Martha Graham school among many
other responsibilities and engagements
she will be the keynote speaker next
month at the humanities at the heart of
healthcare programs sponsored by the
Vermont Humanities Council and then
follow speaking engagements in New York
Virginia Atlantic City and on and on so
the blue hills writing Institute and
curry College is delighted to be one
stop Danyelle on your very busy circuit
so dr. Aphra welcome once again to curry
to the institute Institute were very
very pleased you're with us
I shouldn't do a product placement can
you hear okay thank you it's such a
delight to be here thank you so much
it's very special to be invited here to
speak and to read from this book which
clearly has so much meaning for me this
book covers the time of Medical School
through to the end of residency perhaps
the most intense time in my life short
of delivering my children I'm going to
read the chapter from my book called
Merced and I've chosen that for a number
of reasons one is that allows me to
honor several people one is Bob at one
who chose to include that in his best
American Essays and the other is Helen
at one and show us include that and the
rest of the book in the book singular
intimacy is that she published with
beacon press I also want to acknowledge
the Missouri review which is the
literary magazine in which it first
appeared and if it wasn't for them and
their attention and their concern for
small writers that the story would never
have come to public attention and that
reminds me to remind us all that we
should all be supporting literary
magazines this is the place where new
literature is found where new writers
are published and if we all subscribe to
at least one literary magazine the
Missouri review the Bellevue literary
review or any of the other hundreds of
wonderful labors of love out there and
when it comes holiday time instead of
getting another horrendous tie for your
friends or a mug get them a gift
subscription to a literary magazine
and also I'd like to thank the folks at
Bellevue Hospital Bellevue is the oldest
public hospital in the country and
perhaps his most famous it's been home
to many physicians many artists many
patients and that provides a home for
many people now and allows us to publish
a literary magazine from its corridors
the physicians the patients and the
staff are all very special people who
work in an unusual environment one that
can't be replicated anyplace else the
story Merced takes place at the end of
residency the end of three years of
training in internal medicine and for me
the end of ten years of being at
Bellevue and I've excerpted it down to
fit in the time so if it's a bit jumpy I
apologize and it begins with a quote
from one of my most favorite poems by
the poet John Stone for this is the end
of examination
for this is the beginning of testing for
death will give the final examination
and everyone will pass Johnstone
gaudeamus igitur this is the case of a
23 year old Hispanic female without
significant past medical history who
presented to Bellevue Hospital
complaining of a headache the speaker
droned on Don with the details of the
case that I knew so well I leaned back
in my chair anticipating the accolades
that were going to come after all I was
the one who had the idea to send the
Lyme test in the first place
Mercedes had been to several ers before
showing up at Bellevue three weeks ago
I'd only been doing sick call that day
because one of the other residents had
twisted his knee playing volleyball she
was a classic aseptic meningitis the
kind you'd sent home with aspirin some
chicken soup her cat scan was normal and
the spinal tap just showed a few
lymphocytes but the ER always overreacts
they gave her IV antibiotics even though
there was no hint of the
life-threatening bacterial meningitis
I'll admit that I was a little cocky
that day but I was just 2 months short
of finishing residency and I knew a lot
more medicine than those er guys when I
met Mercedes that first day she was
sleeping on a stretcher in the corner of
the ER with her plump cheeks and wide
brown eyes she didn't even look 17 much
less 23 the sleeves of her pink
sweatshirt were pushed up past her
elbows a gold cross with delicate
filigree was partly obscured by the
folds of the sweatshirt doctor you have
to believe me she said pulling herself
up on the stretcher I have never been
sick a day in my life
it's only this past month that I've been
getting these headaches they come almost
every day and aspirin doesn't do
anything dark must curls spilled over
her pink shirts while she spoke one
hand-woven self absent mindedly in and
out of the locks so what made you come
today I asked this headache it didn't go
away and then my arm and God all pins
and needles for a few minutes just a
couple of minutes but now it's fine
Mercedes smiled slightly and to Tiny Tim
polls flickered in her cheeks
I guess that they got
tired of me complaining so they decided
to let me stay from talking to her I
learned that Mercedes was a single
mother with two children age 3 and 4
based on our history and physical exam I
concluded that she had garden-variety
aseptic meningitis the ER staff with
their usual sledgehammer approach to
medical care had overdone with
intravenous antibiotics just to show
them how a real medicine was done I
wrote of an extensive admission note
from Mercedes detailing all the rare
causes of aseptic meningitis paragraph
after paragraph elucidated my clinical
logic and I printed neatly so it would
be easy for anyone perusing the chart to
read there was an extra tube of Mercedes
cerebrospinal fluid in my pocket so I
decided to send it for a couple of rare
tests including a Lyme titer what the
heck I thought this is a teaching
institution were supposed to waste some
money on exotic tests in order to learn
the next morning during rounds just as I
was dazzling the crowd as my erudite
analysis of Mercedes case the nurses
called me urgently to her room Mercedes
was on the floor with her clothes off
Harris you babbling incoherently her IV
had been pulled out and her body was
splattered with blood completely
disoriented she fought us specifically
as we tried to help her back to bed 30
minutes later she was entirely back to
normal immediately IRA pleaded the
cat-scans spinal tap but the results
were no different than the day before
Mercedes was transferred to the
neurology service for management of
possible encephalitis and I was
transferred off the ward when the other
residents knee got better a week later
I tracked down the intern to see how
Mercedes was doing hey you hear the news
he said that patient really had Lyme
disease the tests just came back
positive yesterday
Lyme disease the test that I had sent
back came back positive I was
exhilarated who would have suspected
that a new york city dweller would have
a disease carried by a deer ticks in the
forest but hey i did a careful
diagnostic evaluation and my
thoroughness had paid off soon everybody
was talking about the case of Lyme
meningitis in our inner-city hospital
the head of my residency program
suggests that I plan a seminar on Lyme
disease meanwhile Mercedes was started
on the appropriate medications for Lyme
she'd been discharged home and was
finishing her three-week course of
antibiotics with daily shots in the
clinic today the case was being
presented at neurology Grand Rounds I
sat back and listened to speaker after
speaker comment on the incredible
diagnosis that had been made residency
would be over at the end of next month I
had been here at Bellevue for ten years
from the beginning of medical school
through my PhD and then my residency ten
years of medical training but now it was
truly paying off ten years of a
scientific approach to medicine had
prepared me for this case someone had
invited Mercedes to the conference and
she sat in the back listening quietly I
watched her from my vantage point in the
corner she looked wonderful her long
curly brown hair was lustrous against
her olive skin
she looked perfectly healthy I smiled
proudly what a true success story I went
to say hello to Mercedes at the end of
the conference I shook her hand heartily
and congratulate her on her recovery her
hand was warm and plump and her
handshake reassuringly healthy the
conference lasted all Friday afternoon I
was looking forward to a relaxing
weekend because Monday was switch day
and I was going to be in the intensive
care unit though I love the ICU I knew
it have no free time for the next month
on June 30th it would all be over in
fact the ICU was a great way to end
residency I'd work like a maniac and
then I'd be done with everything and
that was Friday Monday morning our new
team gathered in the ICU there was a
crackle in the air from all the
different machines breathing life into
our critically ill patients we rounded
on all the new patients as a tightly
organized team talking and easy jargon
with no need to translate for anyone at
each bedside was a computer loaded with
data for each patient we raced each
other to calculate arterial alveolar
gradients and oxygen extraction ratios
for an intern or even a second-year
resident the ICU is a
a fine place especially on the first day
but now I took it all in stride
just another 12 sick patients on
ventilators let him crash let him code I
could handle it
that's what ten years of LV training
does for you that evening I was home
alone gathering my thoughts on my new
patients it was only Monday but it was
clear is going to be an exciting month
my residency is going to end in style I
ran down my list of patients whom could
we improve there was that lady in bed
three on two different antibiotics for
an abdominal abscess maybe she could use
a third eye but that could wait until
tomorrow they all died in bed five who'd
stroked out last month I wasn't sure if
his ventilator settings were optimized
his peak pressures had been fluctuating
if I could get the latest blood gas
results I could make the adjustments
over the phone and then see his new
numbers before rounds in the morning why
wait until tomorrow if I could keep the
patient one step ahead I propped my feet
up on my couch and tore open a bag of
chili and lime tortilla chips one hand
Bao the phone while the other plunge
into the bag instead of the clerk who
usually answers the phone George one of
the other residents happened to answer
we chatted for a while about how much
fun the ICU was what a great way to end
residency I asked how his first night on
call was going what a night George said
we've been incredibly busy one cardiac
arrest one septic shock
my third admission is the most
interesting interesting really I said
what you get to surprise something rare
but you'll see on tomorrow's rounds come
on George I said between chomps of chips
give me a hint I tested him some more
and he finally relented read up on lime
meningitis for tomorrow he said the
chips in chili turned to sawdust in my
mouth that's strange I said I just had a
case of Lyme meningitis three weeks ago
I could feel the muscles in my neck
tightening please God don't let it be
the same person don't let it be Mercedes
yep that's the one George said Mercedes
in the ICU I had just seen her on Friday
and she was fine how could she be in the
ICU on Monday I jammed the telephone
against my ear struggling to absorb this
that was being transmitted on Saturday
George told me Mercedes had experienced
another headache on Sunday her headache
worsened so she came to the ER nothing
was found in physical exam and she was
sent home with a diagnosis of postman
and jeddak headache on Monday this
afternoon she complained of the worst
headache of her life accompanied by
nausea and vomiting this time she was
admitted to the hospital the doctors who
spoke with her said she gave a coherent
history for recent treatment and again
had a perfectly normal normal
neurological exam nonetheless they sent
her for a cat scan of her head the scan
lasted 15 minutes when the technician
went to help her out of the scanner
he found her unresponsive a code was
called but by the time the code team
arrived her pupils were already fixed
and dilated a sign of irreversible brain
swelling she was brought to the ICU
where a hole was drilled in her skull to
relieve the pressure but it was too late
now she lay in bed ten of the ICU
her breathing maintained by a ventilator
brain-dead test for tuberculosis lupus
syphilis vasculitis we're all negative
could this all be from Lyme I stammered
into the phone Nath George replied we
sent another Lyme titer and it came back
negative
this ain't Lyme that first Lyme titer
was a false positive
his voice faded for a moment as he told
one of the nurses to suction bed four
how could a young woman whom we'd
presumably cured who had been so alive
and healthy three days ago be brain dead
now I had been there on Friday I had
touched her and felt her warm and alive
skin just 72 hours ago it couldn't be
the same person I store him back and
forth in the two cramped rooms of my
Manhattan apartment I tore the text
books off the shelves ripping through
the indexes for answers i upended the
contents of my lime folder scouring the
fine print in the scientific papers
hurling them aside when they proved
useless lime in the inner city how could
I have been so stupid I knew there's
nothing I could do the neurosurgeons
were already there and the head of the
infectious disease unit had
personally examine Mercedes besides once
the pupils are fixed and dilated
everyone knows there's nothing you can
do
it was now 2:00 a.m. I tried to convince
myself that it would be for the greater
good of all my patients if I just calmed
down and got a good night of sleep so I
could function in the morning but my
hands wouldn't stop trembling I had
already eaten all the chocolate I could
unearth in my apartment I had to see
Mercedes with my own eyes I pulled on an
old pair of scrubs and set off on First
Avenue the street was quiet even the
homeless had gone off somewhere to sleep
the gloomy Brit behemoths of the old
Bellevue buildings cast spooky shadows
in the moonlight the decaying TB
sanatorium and mental hospital Menace
from behind the tall cast iron gates the
dusky ivy and the brick buildings made
the walls look moist and velvety inside
the hospital
it was brightly lit the wards were alive
with the night shift
orderlies wheeling patients nightfall in
turns placing IVs nurses giving late
night doses of medicines
I felt blurry from the incongruity of it
all
the Mercedes I had seen on Friday had
disappeared and another patient all but
dead had been substituted how could
normal hospital life go on when such an
earthy unearthly alchemy was occurring
in its midst from the ICU doorway I saw
George addressing Mercedes family and
friends who are gathered around bed 10
George was trying vainly to explain the
finality of the situation Mercedes
mother and two sisters were sobbing
openly her brother stood motionless
bewildered George escaped from the
family when he caught sight of me he
didn't seem surprised that I was
standing in the ICU at 2:00 a.m. and an
on-call night I've been trying for hours
to explain her condition to them but
they just won't accept it maybe you can
convince them i hovered by the supply
cart gathering my courage in the surreal
- number of the night ICU the family
appeared like a landscape a range of
backs with shadowed peaks and dips
surrounding a central Canyon the
fluorescent lights from the bed glinted
up off their faces creating awkward
Louis and oddly sculpted ravines I crept
closer to the rocky looking human
formation hoping that no one would
notice me a rivulet of yellowish green
light seeped from between the mother and
one of the cousins and I appeared
between them into the crack of light to
see what lay in bed ten it was Mercedes
the one that I knew with luminous cheeks
and luxurious black hair cascading on
the pillow her eyelids were softly
closed and the dark lashes rested in
delicate parallel lines upon her olive
cheeks her gold filigree cross floated
on the plump unblemished skin of her
neck her respirations were calm and even
thanks to the ventilator apart from the
breathing tube she looked like a
beautiful healthy woman who was only
sleeping from the electronic monitors
overhead though a different story was
evident the red line that indicated the
pressure inside Mercedes head was
undulating menacingly at the edge of the
screen nearly off the scale entirely
despite all the medical interventions
her brain was swelling inside the solid
walls of her skull a pressure chamber
was roiling inside this unforgiving
cranial bones driving the base of her
brain out of the bottom four skull the
respiratory center of her brain was
already destroyed by the relentless
onslaught the Cardiac Center would soon
follow her brother noticed me standing
at behind the crowd and the whole family
turned to me nobody said anything but I
could feel their desperation I was still
trying to convince myself that this was
the same Mercedes this beautiful
sleeping woman whom we'd so triumphantly
diagnosed with Lyme disease and all
because I'd sent that damn test the
intracranial alarm clanged overhead
forcing me to look again at the ominous
red line it was creeping upward
inexorably
mocking my ten years of training my
ludicrous Lyme test it was all over
Mercedes spent Mercedes brain was
flipping out and I had no way to catch
it I gaze of the nine people standing
before me with her swollen eyes and
tear-stained cheeks how could I get them
to believe that it was hopeless
the family waited for words but I could
only stare at Mercedes I wish I weren't
a doctor I wanted the freedom to hold
false hope usually when I've had to
explain to a family that a patient is
dying the patient graciously assists me
by looking the part
they are pale or emaciated or in pain
are struggling for breath they look like
death but Mercedes refused to play along
serenely she lay as beautiful as she'd
been three days ago no scars from
repeated IVs no skin ulcers from
prolonged immobility no she looks
steadfastly alive but there is no gray
area in brain death
Mercedes apparent vitality was just an
illusion created by the ventilator and a
short duration of her condition in a day
or two her body would swell up and her
skin would grow dusky the Cardiac Centre
for brain would be smothered by the
persistent intracranial swelling and her
heart would finally give out then she
would look like the death that we know
the hospital chaplain arrived a rotund
balding Catholic priest who might seen
around the hospital but never met a
bellevue ID card and a wooden crucifix
tangled around from his neck competing
for space on his protuberant belly he
slowly made his way around the bed
touching each family member offering
tissues murmuring softly with his pudgy
white hands he seemed to spread soft
apples of comfort his job looks so much
more palatable than mine he glanced at
me and must have seen a tear welling up
in my eye he silently reached out his
arm and rested it on my shoulder my
stethoscope twisted off my neck onto the
floor as I leaned into his black tunic
and began to cry his arms circled around
me and my body reacted to that touch
unraveling and letting go I collapsed
deeper into his chest sobbing and
sobbing I pray that I would regain my
composure so I could deliver the medical
explanation that I had been dispatched
to deliver but I could not the family
stared with quiet amazement as I cried
uncontrollably into the arms of a
strange priest
unable to stop I mumbled something
incoherent and dashed out of the ICU
stumbling over my stethoscope on the
floor I escaped into a deserted
conference room where I sat hunched over
in the dark I couldn't understand why I
was crying so hard I didn't really know
Mercedes or her family that well I had
only by chance cared for her on the
first two days of her admission and
again only by chance happened to
telephone the ICU tonight for an
unrelated reason I could so easily have
missed one or both parts of her story
but fate had me present at both ends
only 72 hours ago we doctors had
celebrated her prowess and saving her
life we've been so self congratulatory
about our diagnosis were we being
punished for our hubris I cried for
Mercedes I cried for her family and her
two little children I cried for all the
patients who had died during my ten
years at Bellevue and I cried for the
death of my belief that intellect
conquers all when I ran out of tears in
stem and I limped back into the ICU and
said quiet embarrassing advice and
Mercedes family I walked out of Bellevue
in a daze it was raining and I didn't
have an umbrella Dawn hadn't yet risen
over the East River but the air was
lighter I was exhausted but felt
strangely relieved that uncontrollable
nervous energy had finally baited and
the drenching rain felt cleansing I
stayed up the rest of the night and
wrote down as much about Mercedes as I
could remember
for the first time in my 10 years of
medical training sleep did not interest
me three weeks later I completed my
internal medicine residency my ten years
at Bellevue had finally ended there was
little pomp as I left the ICU all alone
on a rainy Sunday morning after my final
36-hour shift bed - was coding but
somebody else was taking care of it
Mercedes continued to haunt me for the
next two years I cornered every neuro
pathologist who could spare a moment to
listen I faxed her case history to
experts at different medical centers and
hounded them with phone calls but no one
had an answer for me
Marcedes autopsy was unrevealing and
every test was negative or non
diagnostic the medical examiner
eventually signed out the case as
unknown etiology what will Mercedes
children think of the medical profession
I've often wondered their mother of whom
will have only dim recollections died
mysteriously and the doctors never knew
why I wanted to go to them and apologize
for our shortcomings our limited
intellect are inadequate tools the false
pride that led us down the wrong path
our utter failure but they are in their
own world being raised by a loving
extended family and while I was
intellectually frustrated I felt
strangely emotionally complete that
night in the ICU with Mercedes was
excruciating ly painful but it was also
perhaps my most authentic experience as
a doctor something was sad and I cried
simple logic but so rarely adhered to in
the high-octane world of academic
medicine standing in the ICU the
chaplains arms around me surrounded by
Mercedes family I felt like a person not
a physician or a scientist or an
emissary from the rational world but a
person like each of the other persons
who were locked in that tight circle
around bed ten there was a strength in
that circle that I'd never felt for my
colleagues or my professors a strength
that allowed me to relinquish the tense
determination for intellectual mastery
that it's so supported me as a doctor
after years of toning those muscles it
was a deliriously aching relief to let
them go slack and it didn't turn me away
from medicine it enticed me I didn't
need a break but I knew that I would
come back I still wanted to learn more
and be a smarter doctor but I also
wanted to be in this world populated
with living breathing feeling people I
wanted to be in the sacred zone that was
a lie with real feelings there's an mine
I didn't know why I had initially
entered the field of Medicine ten years
ago but I now knew why I wanted to stay
thank you
thank you so much I'd be happy to answer
any questions I have to admit to know I
probably wouldn't a breaking book except
that you were going to be here tonight I
read it and I couldn't put it down and I
was struck by the humanity of it and I
think it's very important for all of us
who deal with doctors soon an occasional
basis to be struck by that humanity of
any doctor and my first question
actually was around actually what
someone else has sort of indicated that
all of us I think live lives where on a
day-to-day basis we think oh my god I
need to write a book and yet I was
struck by the detail of your book now
you've just explained Mercedes there was
one other story that I read and it was
about the woman with AIDS there - it
positive yes where you kept questioning
her and it was so moving to me and yet I
kept thinking how did she find the time
to go home at night and I would imagine
every night and write this down did you
do that I wish I did I would say all
through residency I chastised myself for
not keeping a journal I was thinking the
most incredible experiences are coming
by of people's lives of intimate
portrayal of visions into people's lives
that I'll never see again I should be
writing this down and I didn't accept in
the medical chart and then only in the
details of platelet counts and liver
spans a colleague of mine it kept a
journal I envied her you can notice I'm
not doing it but later on it startled me
how much it came back now of course
these are the 15 or 20 most of searing
experiences there are thousands of very
dull blood pressure checks and
cholesterol medication you know
interactions that are not very dramatic
and you know probably don't remember the
details but I would say that you don't
ever forget some of these type of
experiences and they do come back with a
bit of a frightening accuracy so to be
sitting in
you know cafe in Guatemala starting to
jot down a story suddenly all of
Bellevue is back and not just the
feelings but the smells the sights and
the sounds are so distinctive and I
think a lot of it is a sensual
recollection there's one story that I
wrote about putting doing EKG and having
to squeeze the electrode bulbs and the
old EKG jelly comes out crusted jelly
now they don't do iki cheese like that
anymore now it's just a little tape so
the students now don't know the
experience of squeezing that and and
crusty blue jelly comes out and that
feeling brings back that night of doing
that EKG in that patient and so I think
those particular experiences are locked
in and and it's amazing I was surprised
that it came back so easily but yes I've
forgotten all the blood pressure checks
in between some reason or other I'm here
tonight and my wife is sitting in the
ICU at Quincy Medical Center and it's
touch-and-go
and it's kind of strange that I show up
here and that's the first story that
that you read is there anything in your
book or books that deal with making that
final decision absolutely sure there's
some some parts about your making final
decisions and how we how we do them I
guess I would say what perhaps I would
think about if I was you know at an ICU
now is just remembering the patient who
was there I think sometimes we get very
caught up in the technical aspects and
there's a lot in the ICU of machines and
monitors and there's so much data to be
gathered we sometimes forget that a
patient's hiding underneath all those
machines in there and and to remember
and it's sometimes hard for the staff
who maybe never met the patient as a
working person running down the steps
the subway cooking dinner balancing a
checkbook they only see them as a
critically ill person and
I think the family can sometimes be the
connection to remind the staff that this
is a human being
this person's person I loved who took
care of my children who combed my hair
knew who laughed at this joke and I
remember being in the IC with a young
woman who had locked-in syndrome where
she was completely paralyzed but could
communicate with her eyelids only and
her boyfriend had put a photo of her
from before she was ill and I didn't
look anything like her now but every day
we'd look at that photo and say that's
that that person and although we see
just machines and a person looks so
different when they're ill but there is
a person and being able to make that
connection I think could be helpful for
the staff to remember that so I wish her
luck yes
I wanted to tell you how much I enjoyed
the story how it impacted but that's not
really why I came up I came up to say
that you are the kind of doctor that so
many people would like to have as a
doctor you know and that I hope through
the writings you do and through the
literary journal that you have a
Bellevue residents and as you said it's
open to others I hope that the training
for doctors in some way becomes more
structured so that perhaps writing and
reading material that separate from the
technical becomes part of the curriculum
so that the humanity that you express
and is clearly there isn't lost because
so many of us myself included have gone
to doctors who we believe don't have a
human bone or human feeling and I thank
you for sharing what you know well thank
you and I hope that we change that with
some of our doctors I think all those
doctors started out with human bones and
because I see those students they come
to us so idealistic so full of fervor to
take care of patients and they've come
from excellent schools the top of their
class they've all studied literature and
political science and by the time we
finish with them the end of medical
school and residency they can't put two
words together and I think that medical
education is a bit responsible for that
we've also annoyed them a little bit to
the emotions and I think you know the
young medical students who feel so
inadequate and so frightened of their
inabilities are the ones who still have
the capacity to talk with a patient for
two hours and make the patient feel
listened to yet babe can make no
decisions in the grand scheme of things
and I hope they were able to to try and
keep a little bit of that in there I
think more people are involving
Humanities in medicine and I think a
place like Bellevue for all its chaos
well also offer some flexibility and let
some innovative teaching come in and I
weave such a bad reputation some ways
just the crazy Hospital but in fact I
think there's excellent medical care and
many caring people come there I look at
my colleagues in the clinic all people
who could make three times what they're
making here
I have practice yet choose to work at
Bellevue voluntarily and excitedly
because of the rich environment from
both teaching and patient care and a
chance to be in a diverse place and make
a difference in people's lives so I I
think there is lots of promise and I'm
very optimistic if I if I weren't I
would have dropped that long ago but
it's there's always something to keep
you going and I'm so happy to have a
small part in that so please come to
Bellevue we're all invited and I'm
serious overnight teenth is our fifth
poetry and prose reading at Bellevue we
have a prose reading poetry prose
reading each time one of our issues of
our literary magazine comes out and we
gathered a crowd of 100-plus people and
now Bellevue center for literature as
well as for healthcare and the
crossroads of many cultures and it
brings in the community and it's I think
part of the grander scheme of healing
that it's not just the body but other
parts and patients come and people off
the street
so if you're in New York around October
please do come to Bellevue you're warmly
invited
that was a poignant in a wonderful story
and the level of detail especially made
it come alive for me and I'm curious if
you could comment on how you get the
level of detail in the story just right
I mean if that's something that you have
learned to do in in one of your initial
passes or if it's something that you
need to keep going back in and adding to
it or how actually you've made that work
it's an excellent question I think I do
go back and add detail I think a lots of
times in the first draft I just get the
story down thinking the readers gonna
see exactly what I see then I go back
and realize that there are big gaps in
the canvas and I try to envision it
being a movie and so you have to hear
the sound smell the smell see the things
on the side that convey authenticity and
so I often go back and add details I
often ask other people to read it and I
ask them well what are you seeing do you
and I'll see they've missed what I
thought is conveyed not to go back and
put more in so usually my advice is
always to put more detail than you think
is necessary it's kind of like
seasonings in the soup more than you
think you need at least with writing as
opposed to soup you can cancel something
out later if there are too many and
redundant but I think the detail and is
important also because I want to not
everyone's been in a public hospital and
probably many hope never to be in one
but there are certain things that I
wanted to convey that make it real I
mean certain things about the smells and
you know I went back to and while you
are a private hospital recently I hadn't
been there since I was a resident and
there's a different smell in the medical
wards there in the arc Bellevue brings
back horrible memories because I had
some horrible experiences there but that
smell is so distinct different from the
toxic shock syndrome of the Bellevue er
smell and remembering what's it gonna
take for that person who's never been
there to feel that experience know the
weight of your coat the feeling of the
material how hot you are in a hospital
and how sleep-deprived you are and how
that changes your perception of things
so I encourage you to put as much detail
as you can possibly think of in your
writing and you can always trim later
I wondered have you ever had patients
who have written about their particular
illnesses especially somebody who's had
an extended illness or perhaps family
members who've written about their
experiences of going through the illness
wid the family member or perhaps a
friend um I have not though I know many
doctors who have and I've we've toyed a
lot about the idea of trying to have a
writing group with our patients we're
challenged a little bit by a language
barrier and that most of our patients
Wester don't speak English and then it
varies from spanish to Bengali to
Croatian fukken II so trying to get a
uniform language is a little bit
difficult but I have colleagues and
other settings to do with patients who
have written who have actually read some
of their things and I think it's
important I recommend Rafael Campos new
book the healing arts of doctors black
bag of poetry and he talks about working
with patients and some of their writings
and some are extremely moving chapters I
wish some more of my I do have one
patients a writer and he does you know
send me his press clips for new things
that come out but it's not about his
illness
I think writing is healing well I
certainly think it's played a big role
in me from becoming comfortable as being
a doctor I think there are lots of
things about being a physician that
aren't necessarily taught in medical
school we get lots of knowledge lots of
technical knowledge lots of
evidence-based medicine we learn the
skills of researching data but how to
bring that in with a patient and things
were often not prepared to do and when a
patient looks at you and says you know
how am I gonna live or how long do I
have that's a very difficult thing to
answer you won't find that even though
you know from a journal what the
five-year survival rate is and there is
increasingly more attention paid to
those nuances of patient care but I
think writing is not so dissimilar from
thinking about a patient I mean a
patient in some ways speaks in metaphor
they come to you with a complaint or
concern a symptom of pain a headache but
what's really going on is something
could be something completely different
and having to go below the surface and
probe below that is not different from
interpreting a poem which is why I think
the poetry is helpful in learning and
learning medicine that those types of
thinking skills are quite similar and
again the process of writing of thinking
about your character or about your
patient trying to capture their voice
and how many iterations it takes to get
it right is it's a way of getting to
understand the patient and what's really
going on and in a similar way in which I
write and edit so I feel there's been a
lot Caroline I don't think I need one
for the other absolutely but I think
they complement each other and when when
medicine is so frustrating a wonderful
thing is fiction because you can make
everything up you don't have to play by
the rules and the medicine well this
drug interacts with that one you have to
you know and this is not on the
formulary and this is off their
insurance plan so many rules but then
you can make it all up with fiction and
poetry and even with nonfiction you have
the freedom to paint the scene as
powerfully as boldly as you want even
more so than the scene actually was and
you can pull together different parts
that you want to bring to the surface
all which are going to be true
but you have the power to control events
sometimes that lack of power is a
frustrating thing in medicine I see many
residents and students become defeated
by the lack of power lack of control in
the medical environment so much happens
beyond their control so I find that it's
a very helpful process to be doing both
and certainly a relief to be able to
turn from one to the other
first of all I want to thank you for
revealing - to all of us that that
doctors and nurses are human beings and
that in fact they they expend a lot of
energy denying that but we do have very
courageous of you - to expose yourself
in that way secondly I want to ask
question which I asked earlier but for
the benefit of people who aren't here I
am curious how you reconcile your
responsibility towards the patient
confidentiality with your need to write
about your patients boy that is
certainly a tough one I'll say I've
really laid awake many nights thinking
about that because on the one hand I'm
not a reporter a reporter has an
agreement up front this is going to be
published whatever you say can be used
my patients aren't coming to me under
those premises they come to me in a
confidential manner to share their most
vulnerable moments and I don't say oh by
the way I'm a writer so just sign here
and again I didn't start out being a
writer so I didn't really think about a
lil' until after the fact whose story is
it is that their story is it my story
Abraham Verghese he says that every
doctor patient interaction is a drama
and you're the two main characters now
you're both the protagonists and
everything the doctor says the patient
has has an effect on the drama you're
both part of the story and in some ways
you are once the patient opens up the
story to me I'm part of the story
I'm an actor in their story on the other
hand my first duty is toward them and if
I thought that it would be harmful I
wouldn't do it should I obtain their
consent and there's a range of opinion
and believe me that's the question I
asked every physician writer I come
across what do you do without that and
there's a range of answer some get
consent some never mentioned and just
change the details of course they do
change names details countries of origin
that's what gets used the fiction skills
to change a little bit of that at times
with some of the staff I would composite
some characters the characteristics of
different interns I'd put them together
to be truthful to the character of the
person but it'd make them
less recognizable so I I don't ask
consent but I would inform the patient
about this story and if they wanted to
read out let them do it if they were
dreadfully opposed than I would withdraw
the story because I am their doctor
first not not a writer but I hope that
it's ultimately an honouring process and
in a respectful manner that I am
pointing out what an important person
this is how much they can contribute to
my education as a physician how much
I've learned and lessons hopefully they
can share with other doctors and other
people so I I hope that they would find
it to be an honoring experience but if
they didn't I think I would have to
withdraw a story
I was most impressed by your your
reading and by your book what struck me
is that to some extent the telling of
the story for you was a coming to
understanding and that's a magnificent
thing and yet at the back of my mind I'm
saying what about the patients do they
get a chance to come to understanding
they have so much less time their fear
is so much greater can what do you think
can anything be done
could anything be done in terms of
writing or overall in discussion with
the patient either I don't know well I
think for for myself for talking with
the patient sometimes for patients I'd
say I haven't written about often go
through a similar process of thinking
about it and for the patient's I know
for a long time there's a chance to go
back I had a patient recently was in the
hospital for many many months so there
was a lot of time to go back and have
ongoing discussions with her and the
first two or three times were very wrote
and routine and she resented me and I
resented her and I think only after time
as we both saw what what was bubbling
underneath you know her frustrations
about her care made me the easy bad guy
to take it out on it and of course her
vocal trance and non-compliance made it
easy for me to not this patient on
arounds again but if we have enough time
we can get there I think one of the
problems were often lacking for time
because it takes as it takes several
iterations or many to write a story
takes many to have interaction that's
meaningful with a patient sometimes
takes many or to get to the root of what
is going on and I regret that so often
we're left with just 15 minutes to do it
or or less sometimes but if we're lucky
we have a chance to get back and keep
going with the patient to see what else
is going beneath the surface to allow
them to come to some amount of
understanding but sometimes we're not
able to or sometimes we're stuck with an
interpreter or the interpreters our
five-year-old child the only one who
speaks their language and can interpret
so inherent limitations to that or their
unconscious or their severely challenged
a cognitive deficit or or their current
illness so sometimes we miss the chance
or don't have the chance and those are
profound regrets everybody else will
move it to their height Allen didn't but
when I listen to you and I and I think
about memoirs I think memoirs are our
reflection reflection on ourselves
reflection on the moments reflection on
possibly the end just trying to
understand only ourselves but ourselves
in the moment and other people's and
other people in that moment I was struck
by one I believe it's one of the
beginning chapters in which you were
fearful and that was every chapter
that's true
but this in this particular chapter you
or we you were struck by the fact that
you were had been pricked by a needle
yeah and you were fearful and I and I
guess I'd like you to comment on that
and comment not only on that moment but
on how many other moments that you may
have been fearful and thank you you just
led right into the answer I think I
think the the prime emotion during
residency is fear fear that you're gonna
kill the patient that's the first one
fear that you won't know what to do they
look like an idiot the patient won't
know it
and that you'll prick yourself with an
HIV positive or hepatitis C positive
needle but there's a lot of fear I think
fear of humiliation is so powerful we
all are so afraid to look stupid on
rounds and I was telling someone earlier
about rounding in a medical student
referred to the belly button was so
humiliated by the response that only be
humble like us from now on you know if
belly buttons will never see their way
in the dance floor again and I felt
terrible that we that the student was
humiliated by just being an honest
answer about a belly button so I think
there's fear on so many levels part of
which I think is a problem with the
system I mean there's a healthy amount
of fear that you do the right thing and
read up make sure you know how not to
kill the patient and I always reassure
the students very few ways to kill a
patient you really it's very hard to do
and
unlikely to happen so I mean played by
the rules but it's not that that easy
but there is a lot of fear because you
don't know what you're doing there's so
much more that you don't know than what
you do know especially the beginning but
even later on there's still more that I
don't know than I do know even at this
stage and it will always be the way
because new knowledge keeps coming in I
can't keep up with it all so I think
learning how to be comfortable with with
doing a good enough job I don't know
every detail about paroxysmal nocturnal
hemoglobinuria but I know where to look
it up and I know how to speak with the
patient so fear is very hard I think
being stuck with a needle is a bit of an
initiation right unfortunately for
almost every medical professional being
stuck at some point and your own
mortality suddenly rising into the
foreground oh my gosh I could HIV and of
course many people have and certainly
more of gotten hepatitis and I mean at
that time there was no one to deal with
it know it just last year one of my
students was pricked with an
hiv-positive needle and the response was
so different you know suddenly there was
you know 20 people down to help her and
there was a needle stick beeper someone
to page for advice and counseling of
what to do and medications to take so I
think in a short time we've really
changed how to deal with some of that
fear but it never goes away and which is
why I think we as the teachers need to
be attuned to the fear in our students
especially as it becomes a little
overwhelming for them and can sometimes
paralyze them but you're right fiords
finding by the seat of your pants are
two things that run through all of
medical training I hate to inform you of
the head but there's good oversight so
don't worry okay good
what I'm I the fact is that you talk
about the fear and about the medical
training and about your own concern and
perhaps doubt that you've experienced
what concerns some readers myself
included and that's why I think your
audience perhaps one day might be the
doctors who have long forgotten
the hubris that many doctors have and in
other words and having that they lost
the skill to either empathize or
communicate and I'm not making an
indictment against the medical
profession because each doctor is an
individual but I'm saying that there are
those there are some and probably all of
us in this room may have encountered one
or two of those and I would just love to
know that these doctors that doctors in
general read what you write what other
doctors write and maybe that will invite
them into the process of reflection and
writing and Qi and in other words
perhaps it's fear that gives them this
hubris I don't know but I do know as a
patient and as a layman it's off-putting
and I think you put your your finger on
the key I think that hubris is the
flipside of fear I think that many
doctors are not all but act in this
hubris type manner because of their fear
and I think we're afraid to acknowledge
your fear if you cannot as your fear
well then the floodgates will just come
open and you'll be drowned in all the
emotion which is why I think many
doctors choose to disengage a bit and
you're right if you keep doing that
enough you become ossified in that
matter and I think part of our job is to
help recognize that fear is a natural
part of course you'd be afraid taking
care of people with their lives and
ventilators you'd be crazy for not
afraid and I think if we acknowledge
that and help people realize that it's
okay it's normal to be afraid okay now
they're all afraid how can we we go
forward I think there are some very
promising trends I think many of the
medical journals now have literary
columns there's poetry there are
photographs now in many of the larger
medical journals and they're amongst the
most popular parts people I know always
turn to those parts first and get to the
clinical trials later but I think there
is a yearning for some aesthetic for
poetry for something beautiful to
acknowledge that there is beauty in even
in the Diaries of medical circumstances
there
Beauty even if it's just a moment you
connect with the patient for one second
that's a beautiful moment despite the
fact that they're dying I mean people
die this is medicine it's not accounting
and there's no way around that and it
often can be horrible and painful and
smelly and uncomfortable but that's why
we're there I think the privilege of
being allowed to be in at this most
vulnerable and unique moment is
something that should I think give us
some humility that were we're honored to
be here and that it is really a
privilege and that moment can be
beautiful and can be the payback for all
of the that what you put into it which
is a lot but it's certainly worth it so
I think there's there's one for hope
medical writers from other countries
where there isn't the same sort of
medical system she has if our journal
the Bellevue literary review has writers
from other countries we've published a
few anyone we trained it has to be in
English we've published writers from
Israel we've published writers from
Alaska and it's not quite another
country but from experiences in Nepal so
a few Asian countries from India I think
there are definitely different
experiences but I think the grain of
humanity runs through no matter what
medical system you have whether it's
socialized medicine or a third-party
payer or free-for-all there's still a
common line and it's it's there because
your medicine can never be made
efficient like a factory line in the end
no matter how big your clinical trial is
it stole one patient one doctor in a
room or at a bedside and it always comes
down to that tiny one-on-one so it's
always a human you always take a pulse
with your fingers and and you can't
automate medicine so that the part
that's the part that gives me hope it
can never be done by robots well I hope
not but I think all right now it's still
going to be down to two people
connecting and actually in a physical
way they have to touch each other
one more question thank you yes
about Mercedes family and if they've
read your book and the essay if you've
received any response from them I have
not heard from them and this is more
than 10 years ago so I I don't know
where they are and that's part of the
wonder of will some of these patients
that come across it like I said most of
the patient's have either died or I've
been in removed circumstances but I
haven't heard I I expect that I might
you know I connected with one patient
from the book who we had a good
interaction over that and and but most
have left the system and a little bit
reflects the population of Bellevue but
trans need a lot of immigrants you know
a lot of poverty so people drift in out
of the medical system I wish I had a way
to connect to them but I wouldn't use
any hospital chart privileges to find
them that wouldn't be right so if I do
run across them I I hope they'll be
honored but I understand if they weren't